michael jordan told me after they swept  us  before you succeed you must first learn  to fail  and i just got tired of failing so one  time we got swept by the stir spurs and  i went in the bathroom and i ripped up  all the toilets  all the urinals it was flying everywhere  and  excuse my french dylan  it was just flying everywhere and jerry  west came in there and he grabbed me and  he was strong as hell too and he put me  up against the mirror calm down it's  like i'm tired of losing he's like you  gonna get it done i went to the finals  eight times in a row before i won and  lost and i was like  and like my soul just left my body i was  like what  i'm like hold on say that again he's  like yeah i went there anytime you know  we could never beat the celtics so i  didn't feel as bad but  i still had that hunger and i was like  okay not only am i gonna do it for me  i'm gonna do it for you too mr west